when it comes to musicians and
performers around the world
i think it's a pretty well established
fact that a lot of people would view it
as kind of a dream come true to be able
to perform
at the iconic sydney opera house as
someone who's lived in sydney my
entire life i've kind of looked at this
amazingly beautiful and striking
building from afar and and thought to
myself well i'm not a performer that's
not something i would ever
aspire to but as a mathematics teacher
i've looked at that building
very differently i've always wanted to
say actually you know what
i want to help people understand there's
some beautiful mathematics
and geometry in the design of this
incredible building something that
millions of people who recognize the
building
don't actually know about it so i was
incredibly privileged
that earlier this year i was able to
work with the sydney opera house
themselves to create a series of videos
called the mathematics
of the sydney opera house i was very
fortunate to have a huge amount of
access to
the internal spaces to speak with
experts in acoustics and architecture to
be able to ask them questions
and hopefully help you guys understand
what a beautiful building this is
and to appreciate just how much
mathematics went into it
so i want to say an enormous thank you
to the sydney opera house and all the
experts i got to speak to
if you want to see the full videos and
also the worksheets that go along with
them if you're a student or a teacher
who wants to explore these ideas further
then head to the sydney opera house
website
but i'm really delighted that i get to
share with you a little bit of a teaser
from the four different episodes of what
you can expect
so here you go
[Music]
the sydney opera house is one of the
most iconic buildings in the world
it's utterly unique instantly
recognizable
and described on the unesco world
heritage listing as a work of creative
genius but it was almost never built
why
[Music]
sir ov arab was the structural engineer
brought on board to make its dream
a reality ootsin's competition entry
contained
fanciful freehand sketches that were
impressive but weren't based on any
specific mathematical shape
arab guided his younger friend towards
geometric figures
that could be planned out precisely at
large scales
but none of them were quite right
for instance the strongest shape would
be a catenary dome
this design perfectly distributes all of
its weight along the structure
you can make your own containery by
taking a chain or a piece of string
and suspending it from two points turn
the shape upside down and get a
containery arch
rotate that through three dimensions and
you get a catenary dome
this kind of shape is marvelously strong
and stable
but it couldn't be used for the sydney
opera house because uts design called
for
sharp ridges along the top of the
structure and continuous domes
are smooth the musical instruments that
perform here at the sydney opera house
come in all shapes
and sizes as part of what gears each its
signature sound
this acoustic guitar for instance makes
and projects unique sounds
through the specific shape or geometry
of its body
let's see if an acoustic engineer can
tell us how the specific shapes of
theaters affect our experience of sound
inside them
the amount of reverberation can be
calculated precisely
using savings formula where v is the
amount of volume in the space
s is the area of each surface in that
space
and alpha is the number that tells us
how much each of those surfaces
absorbs sound urton's key insight was
that you could take the uniform
curvature of a sphere
and nonetheless cut out many different
shapes from it
just like a single musical instrument
can play many different songs
so too can a single sphere make many
different shells
and this is how the iconic sails were
ultimately created
the beautiful chevron pattern is visible
from afar
but it's only when you get close that
you can see it's composed of individual
matte and glossy tiles since the
chevrons get wider as you climb the
structure
you need a larger number of matte tiles
for each successive chevron which is
given by this equation
but the chevrons are all essentially the
same height
so the side tiles alternate between 24
and 26 tiles
depending on whether it's an odd or even
chevron as lewis khan the american
architect put it the sun did not know
how
beautiful its light was until it was
reflected off of this building
looking at the sydney opera house from a
distance is awe-inspiring
but it's when you come in close that you
realize how many tiny details
come together to produce this singular
experience of wonder
every part of the world has its own
unique architectural style
buildings in europe are different to
buildings in asia which are different
again to those in africa
and the islands of the pacific but more
than 10 million people from all around
the world
more than double the population of
sydney itself visit the sydney opera
house every single year
because yorn utsun gave the building
universal qualities that appeal to
people
from all cultures well i think we often
if we sent to someone to use rigid
geometry
we might imagine them coming up with
something very fixed
straight lines which is almost the exact
opposite of what we have here absolutely
but the same rigor geometry grigor is
here
as is in a building with straight lines
and
and right angles and that's the
brilliance of it
utzen brought a sophisticated
understanding of geometry and artistic
expression to his design
one that was inspired by the
mathematical shapes found in nature
fractal geometry the curve of a leaf
the crashing waves of a harbor but his
lofty thoughts
never took him away from remembering
that the sydney opera house was always
to be a medium
for human experience so he designed
every aspect of the building with the
perspective of an individual in mind
that's why to this day it's such a
moving experience to approach
and enter the sydney opera house